Maisie!
It is so good to see you.
-Hi!
-You look fantastic.
-Thank you for having me back.
-So happy to have you b--
Wait. We have to talk about
the last time you were on
because seriously --
-It was crazy.
-It was April Fool's,
and we pranked our audience
to think that you spoiled
"Game of Thrones," the ending.
-The end of the show.
Not just your audience.
The entire world.
-I think it's over
24 million hits on YouTube.
-It's crazy.
That was probably
the most successful thing
I did last year,
and I was on the final season
of "Game of Thrones."
-No, I mean -- Well, gosh.
In case you haven't seen it,
here's our April Fool's prank.
Take a look at this.
This is a prank.
-When I found that Arya died
in, like, the second episode,
I was...
-Are you s-- What?
-Is this live?
-No.
-We can edit that.
-Are you serious?
-Yeah.
-Let's talk about
the final season.
-I'm s--
-Is she okay?
I'm gonna just go...
-April Fool's!
-Dude, honestly.
I have to stop there.
I could never top that.
That's the best acting
I've ever done in my life.
We work well together.
But you --
you started shaking and, like...
And I was like...
-You know,
I find these
talk shows in person
actually more nerve-racking
than it is, like,
sitting in my kitchen.
But I was so nervous
coming on the show,
and I'm such a big fan
of the show,
and I'd never done it before.
And so I basically
was just letting myself --
letting all of the nerves
just come out in that moment.
And I can hear people
in the audience,
and they're whispering,
and I'm thinking,
"Oh, they're not buying it."
And, like, when I look back now,
I realize that it was probably,
like, nervous laughter.
But at the time, I was like,
"They are not buying this.
I'm going to have to ham this up
and, like, turn on the tears
and get these people...
-No, you did.
You had the tears.
They were just --
They were on the edge.
Like a meniscus around your eye.
And I was like --
And then I felt so bad.
This is like so --
I do not do tricks.
I don't do pranks.
I go, "Oh, no, no, no."
I felt so bad for you
'cause it was
your first time on,
and I'm making you do this bit.
And I go --
And then -- Oh, my gosh.
Honestly, I was exhausted.
I can't even imagine
what you go through acting,
because if that's
what acting is,
I'm not cut out for that at all.
I was exhausted.
I had to take like a month off
just to sleep
and get my energy back.
-You nailed it.
It was just beautiful.
Any time you're in a movie,
I've got to be in that movie
with you.
-We have good chemistry, bud.
I appreciate that.
You started "Game of Thrones"
when you were 12.
So this is the first time
in ten years
that you don't have to
worry about spoilers.
How does that feel?
-It is so nice.
I used to walk down the street,
and every single person
that would recognize me,
the only thing they'd ever
want to know is, like,
"Tell me what happens
in the next season.
Did Jon Snow really die?
Are you going to be
blind forever?"
Like, all of these things
that I just couldn't talk about.
Now I guess people
actually just ask me like,
"What did you think
of the final season?"
Because there's a lot
of speculation over, you know,
the success of it.
-Yes. Should Arya
have won the throne?
Was that the right way to go?
Let me tell you something. No
one wants anything good to end.
There is no --
You just don't want it to end.
So no matter what it was,
it's perfect.
It was great.
-Oh, thank you.
No. We had such a blast.
We loved it.
I was so happy with my ending,
and it was just a beautiful end
to a decade of my life.
And I just -- I couldn't be
happier with it, honestly.
-When did you know?
Did you film different endings?
Or did you know kind of
before it was happening?
Like, oops.
-No, yeah, we --
So, we just had one script
the whole time.
But in terms of, like,
finding out the story,
I was actually --
I was at, like,
a costume fitting
before we had received the
scripts for the final season,
and, um, I was, like,
looking on the wall,
because they had the breakdown
of every scene.
Had, like, one sentence
of what was going on.
And I was looking
at episode three
because it was called
"The Long Night,"
and I was like, "Ooh,
that sounds like a battle."
And so I'm, like,
looking through,
and it says,
"Arya is with B
and then Arya is with the hound
and then with Mel."
And all these, like,
kind of code names.
And then I got to a scene,
and it said, "Arya kills NK."
And I was like, "Who is NK?"
Like, who -- I had no idea
which character that is.
And it turns out
it was the Night King.
It was like THE character.
-THE NK.
-The guy to kill. NK.
And I was thrilled.
Absolutely thrilled.
-That was awesome.
And what a performance,
too, man.
I was just -- It was a crusher.
Congrats on all that stuff.
I want to get to your movies.
But also quickly,
I saw that you've been getting
into video games
the past few months,
and you debated --
-I have.
-Playing on Twitch.
-Video games got me -- Yeah.
Got me through this lockdown.
-What are you playing?
What are you playing?
-I've been playing
"Animal Crossing."
-Yes.
-Uh, "Minecraft."
I played this really great game
called "Conduct TOGETHER!"
And you're basically,
like, a train conductor
and you have to make sure
that trains don't crash
into each other
and all of the people get
picked up from their stations
at the correct --
It's ridiculous,
but, honestly...
it is so fun.
-"Conduct TOGETHER!"?
-"Conduct TOGETHER!"
-Wow.
-You have to play it
with a partner, though.
'Cause trying to do that,
like, alone with both --
'Cause one controller
starts and stops,
and the other controller...
-Picks people up?
-...changes the tracks.
-Oh, changes the track?
-And so trying to do both,
it's like scratching your head
and rubbing your tummy.
-My wife will never do that
with me. No, no, no, no, no.
So I could never play that game.
Oh, you know what game
I'm playing, which is good?
Have you played "Fall Guys"?
-[ Gasps ] I just played this
the other day
for the first time!
-It's fun, right?
-Yes. So much fun.
-If any of you at home
don't know what it is --
It's probably
on all the systems.
But you basically
drop out of the sky,
and then you go online
against 60 people
and you do, like,
an online obstacle course,
and you're, like, these
blobby type of people,
and it's really fun.
And it's short.
-They way they're animated,
as well.
Like, they're so stupid.
[ Laughs ]
They fall over
and, like, flip around.
They're really funny.
I love them.
-I'm going to get a friend and
then play "Conduct TOGETHER!"
But in the meantime, you have
a few protects coming up.
"The Owners" is in theaters
and on demand September 4th.
This is like a creepy thriller
with, like, twists,
and it's scary.
Are you a fan of those movies?
-I am.
Psychological thrillers are --
and, like, horror
is my favorite genre.
And I always love
watching these movies.
And so it was
a real dream come true
to be a part of
something like that.
And, yeah, I mean, on set,
like, you know, it's always
just way more fun
than it looks on camera.
You're, like, screaming
and covered in blood,
and it's like a nightmare,
but on set,
we're just in this, like,
beautiful home
in Southwest London
in the middle of summer
just, you know,
having a great time.
-Screaming and covered in blood.
-Yeah. Sometimes.
Occasionally.
And then occasionally
having a lovely dinner.
-It's a good story.
It's really fun.
I was like, "Oh. Oh, wow.
Okay.
So now we flip the script.
Okay. Interesting."
And then "The New Mutants"
is in theaters August 28th.
People are freaking out
waiting for this to come out.
You filmed this three years ago.
Is that correct?
-Three years ago,
and we have had --
I found out today this is
our fifth release date
that we've ever had.
And this is the first time
we've ever got this far.
So our tickets went on sale
yesterday.
And so it feels real this time!
-It's official!
It's coming out!
-Yes.
-It's coming out!
-Yeah. But I'm so excited
for this movie to come out.
I still love it as much as I did
the day that I signed on.
And there's been a lot of rumors
as to why this film was delayed.
But honestly, no other film
was affected as much as ours was
in the merger.
And there's no other reason
than that.
People are going to love it.
It's a beautiful story.
And I just can't wait
for people to finally see it.
-Yeah. People are going crazy.
At one point,
I read somewhere that --
I think someone said
the director described it
as Stephen King
meets John Hughes.
-Yes. Exactly that.
Nail on the head.
-Because you're teenagers.
Is that why?
-Exactly. Yes.
We are these, like,
teenage mutants.
It's not look like
a typical superhero film
where we've got it all
figured out
and we're saving the world.
We actually are all
kind of trapped
in this medical facility,
and we're trying to
harness our powers.
We still don't understand
how to use them.
We keep harming other people
and harming ourselves.
And so it's down
to Dr. Cecilia Reyes,
who is in charge
of looking after us
and teaching us how to -- how to
control ourselves, effectively.
But they're also just teenagers
who are just trying to grow up,
and their bodies are changing,
and they also have superpowers.
And I think it's just very
relatable for a lot of people,
a lot of young people also.
I think the younger generation
are the most resilient.
They've been through so much
in, like,
such a short space of time.
And I think this movie
really plays into that.
Like, really high stakes
and really immense pressure
and also in the middle of it
just trying to be a teenager
and fall in love and live life.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Maisie Williams
in "The New Mutants"
in theaters August 28th.
Take a look.
[ Rumbling ]
♪♪
-It's up to us.
-No. It's hunting Dani.
-Why Dani?
-Because that's what she fears.
Come on. Help me.
-All right. One, two, three.
-[ Grunts ]
♪♪
-Take Dani to a safe place.
And I'll take care of this bear.
[ Shouting in foreign language ]
[ Electricity crackles ]
♪♪
-What are you going to do?
-I'm going to play with them.
-Fantastic.